there are a few Signs of Life at many
shopping districts in the Chinese
Capital fears of a looming covid-19
outbreak are keeping many people off the
streets
Mr Chen barely sees any customers at his
tea shop these days but he's holding out
hope that business will bounce back
the pandemic will eventually go away
it'll take some time but I believe
things will recover step by step and my
business will gradually improve
the latest official economic data is
less optimistic
for the second consecutive month retail
sales slumped almost six percent on last
year investment and Industrial growth
both slowed in November and unemployment
Rose to the highest since May
policymakers are launching huge stimulus
measures and pumping billions of dollars
into the banking system but analysts say
it may take more than just money to
spark an economic rebound so there's a
lot of fear in the country right now so
consumers frankly just are not willing
to go outside to restaurants a lot of
parents are refusing to send their
children to school because they're
scared of the families catching covid so
I think the economy is in a very weak
State much weaker than most analysts
realize the sudden relaxation of
long-standing pandemic restrictions has
seen some Shoppers stockpiling at
supermarkets and pharmacies
I am very worried the problem is I can't
buy any medicine now what should I do if
I get a fever it's too risky to go out
the government is trying to reassure the
public that everything is under control
it's boosting vaccine production rolling
out more booster shots for the elderly
and ordering hospitals to increase
capacity at intensive care units but
International Health experts say China's
lack of exposure to the virus over the
past three years and its low vaccination
rate among seniors means there's a risk
that around a million people could die
as the country rapidly transitions out
of its zero covid policy Richard Kimber
Al Jazeera Hong Kong